the solution of the previous quiz said
that we had to define the wide detail
fragment layout in two places the layout
land and the layout SW 600 DP folder to
avoid having multiple copies of this
file we should use layout aliasing we
can check the documentation for layout
aliases to see an example say we have a
main layout file that's for one pane UI
in the layout large and layout SW 600 DP
folders we want a multi pane layout in
case you're wondering layout large is
for backward compatibility purposes for
large devices prior to Android 3.2
that's when the SW qualifiers were
introduced so back to the point to avoid
code duplication we can define the two
pane layout in the base layout folder
then in the value is large and values SW
600 DP folders we can create a reference
so that the main layout actually maps to
the two pane layout in the java code you
can reference it as our layout main but
is actually referencing the two pane
layout this is what the detail fragment
should look like afterwards and this is
what the phone landscape view looks like
if you rotate the device the phone
portrait view should be different in the
next coding task we're going to make the
today list item look more like the other
items in the list for the tablet